okay so the bot is called ttv chat
i'm gonna send a challenge
hello eric have a wonderful day
oh thanks you too okay we're gonna keep
it chill and do like 10
10 30.
this should be oh this should be rated
or the unrated
okay let's see how this goes
okay so basically chat can vote on the
moves
let's play sicilian
okay
so now now chad is on screen because i i
might put this on youtube
and youtube will have a better idea of
what's happening
and we can see the stats on this side
so hopefully this is this is still
watchable
enlarge this a little bit
okay chat good luck i i'm playing my
normal
main rapper tour i didn't want to mess
with stafford gambits
oh this is so freaky i'm playing against
a few hundred of you
ray spamming bishop g5 oh
bishop wait bishop g5 doesn't work
though
oh but maybe just trying to
self-destruct
knight c3 has the most votes
it's actually nice to see like the stats
in real time
so i know which move to expect okay
so far we're playing main line i mean
chad is playing like a gm
yeah if you're just joining hopefully
you i assume people just joining can
figure out what's going on
so bishop e3 yeah bishop e3 is still
this is very mainline
oh how many people are stream sniping
probably all of you right
there has to be at least one like
morally ethical person
who's like muted the stream and just
typing in moves
or maybe there's one person whose sound
isn't working
that's probably more likely bishop c4
wow bishop c4 is the first
like kind of not good move
but can we punish it
because in general like the bishop it's
restricted by the pawns
so
like my first impression is to take but
then queen takes and
i can't take the bishop i might just
keep developing like just knight f6
oh yeah so the chat versus ericbot
uh will will provide more information
whoa rookie mistakes gifting a sub
to anti-matter pillow thanks rookie
mistakes
hmm bishop b3 good move
yeah bishop b3 okay so it's like uh what
is this called yugoslav attack
so you're playing a yugoslav attack
against mai taimanov
which is kind of bizarre
because the the bishop is undermined
bishops don't like to stare at pawn
chains
oh did so someone put it in emote only
mode
i i was thinking about that earlier
that's a great way to mess with people
so emote only mode would allow
it would still allow mods and vips to
to vote ooh a3 blundering
a pawn
everyone's trying to castle
i don't think you can vote for an
illegal move
there's only one two there's five legal
moves here
king you two with three votes four votes
okay i'm just realizing if i take the
pawn
i don't want to say i don't want to say
if i take the pawn white has a cool move
and it gets weird
whoa it's bits from bobo baggins
lego is that is that what they say in
france
lego lego
okay so white has a cool move
do i do it
i'm not sure i guess i'll do it
i'm not revealing the cool move oh but
oh oh people in the chat know
uh oh queen g4 is coming
don't do it two votes for kingi too come
on just vote for kini two
ah yeah queen g4
so i can't really play hope chess
okay so my idea was queen e5 i defend
everything
the queen's a little bit overworked but
i don't know if i can take advantage of
it
this would be interesting takes takes
and then everything's attacked
king 2 has three votes oh chad is
conflicted
when king you two has three votes you
know you're in trouble
do you have a favorite music album oh
uh album like
a collection of songs
i don't i don't even know if i can name
an album
i just listened to songs it's been a
while
probably something by
i used to listen to don mclean whatever
like the american pie album was
okay so white's developing the king
very fancy oh maybe this was a plan
because now white's controlling more
center and attacking my knight
my queen is vulnerable hmm
thinking f5 here
f5 is kind of a cool move
i could retreat
maybe i'll retreat first
f5 will kind of be a a weapon to
deploy later
is this king no this is not king of the
hill i i was the one who sent the
challenge
so king kc4 so i think we can conclude
chat
is is more of a troll than
a grandmaster can i just take this
you can just take this
look at this move it's so beautiful
because if takes i fork
it's kind of like the the wooden shield
no it's more like an octopus
knight on e3 would have so many
tentacles
king c5 wow i i thought i thought it was
going to be a challenge after queen g4
what is this
uh
i'm so confused maybe b6 let's play b6
you have two legal moves
king d6 and coming wow
no one wants to play oh two people for
king c4
this is why we can't have nice things
to say to say ggchat
gg i'm i'm wondering now
but there's there's so many ideas to to
do with this
i i'm wondering if i could beat chat
with queen odds
or like blindfold or bulge can i do
bullets
we could do like five second voting
right
okay that was fun i was okay this is
like this feels historic
never done anything like this i hope
people enjoy that
chat you are part of history
say hi to youtube because you'll you'll
be immortalized on youtube
i hope people behave themselves
clearly some people didn't behave
themselves developing their king
like a madman at least the king got some
exercise
it's like it's kind of like climbing
mount everest
but that was a unfortunate ending
yeah so next time
um don't play bishop c4 bishops don't
like to be
on squares where they're restricted by
pawns so a better move
uh one idea is to play queen d2
queenside castle usually combined with
f3
another idea is bishop e2 and kingside
castle
it's a so-called classical variation
um the trendy move here is queen f3
oh lycha's child is active too ooh
queen f3 has been like the attempt at
refuting the taiwan of
anyway um yeah that
that'll go on youtube youtube people
this is why you should follow on twitch
you can participate in real time